c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
bon à cet été les shérifs vous allez me
manquer mais je pars dès ce dimanche
multiples tournées pour le théâtre pièce
de réveillon d'essayer on part joué à
narbonne perpignan et nice après voilà
et après je pars la ligue 1 voilà le
piège gros parents que j'adore en face
voilà pour une semaine écrit et après
biarritz mon fief à moi j'ai ma maman
j'adore aussi
et après un peu là la riviera voilà
quatre jours après je blue glow ce que
je sais pour le moment c'est que je vais
faire découvrir l'italie à ma fille on
va aller à rome
et puis je pense qu'on va aller se
promener un peu sur la côte mais je vais
lui faire découvrir aux mails avaient
envie d'aller en italie donc l'italie
cesare ça c'est sûr après c'est
l'inconnu s'est pas fixé encore pas
décidé
[Musique]